[Music]
welcome
everybody to the h3 podcast soundboard
experience a little late on the uptake
there guys but
better you know pretty close thank you
to today's sponsors
host mates dollar shave club that really
it's so long
and uh for him coming up
in the month ahead we've got
jacksepticeye
the uh sweetest man on youtube coming up
next week bert kreischer
nice we've been waiting and waiting to
get bert kreischer in here super funny
comedian
yeah love him great he was actually one
of our
first earliest guests we've had on here
it was such a funny episode
yeah lost into oblivion
technical difficulties and uh he just he
deserves better than that
you know i felt bad about that but we're
gonna do good
the second this one's not gonna be as
good as that one nothing will ever talk
it's like that tenacious d song the
greatest song in the world
you know that song yeah it's like that
nothing will ever be as great as the
greatest song in the world but this is a
tribute to it
and then after that we've got tim hi
decker hey
that's exciting and then after that yet
again later in the month
adam carolla what all sealed in
great wonderful guests huge month ahead
very excited thank you
and uh before we get into it you guys
have seen us
rocking grateful dead merch i love
grateful dead i love their merch
as much as i love their music well guess
what
we got our own grateful dead inspired
merch say what
you can't really yeah take the camera
peel it down
she gets naked here for a sec look at
this oh my god
so sick h3 productions you got shredder
you got both of us i mean it's sick
tie-dye soda represent.com h3
and the extra thick extra thick hat
[Music]
where you at love it so yeah represent
dude this shirt is sick i am going to
wear
this shirt straight up shane dawson
style
i'm gonna wear this everywhere because i
love it that much
um that's about it i've got a question
did you say the link though because it's
representative.com h3h3
we had it on the screen as well okay
this one this is what all the sponsors
make you do they go
r r e p s r e s
e n t dot com you just may spell yeah i
don't know
yeah i don't know how to spell
represent.gov
slash h3 twice
just look what's on the screen i don't
know what i'm doing
um let me ask you this ela
what when you give somebody food you
feed them
right but when you give somebody water
what is that verb called you will water
them
there's no word for that is there what
is the word for when you give somebody
water when you
give them a drink not feed could you say
feed them water no you drink them
there's no word how is there no word for
that
quench you don't watch
i quenched him no you water flowers
right
yeah but you don't want that doesn't
mean this like this has been really
troubling me this week
people say ethan you've got serious
troubles people say
ethan you haven't been posting videos
and disappeared what the hell have you
been traveling here i haven't been able
to get over the fact
this whole week that there's no word for
the word to drink to give somebody water
in the english language we have we're
celebrated for having hundreds of
thousands
by far the most words of any language
that ever existed english language no
word for giving water
anybody in the chat gotta answer there's
no chat there's no chat
that's true i don't think there's a i
don't think it exists
to drink so that's been really
driving keep it me up at night frankly
speaking
maybe in the comments you guys will
figure it out
but guys i googled it and for a baby you
suckle them
yeah that's something that only applies
that sounds right oh uh yeah my friend
was thirsty so i
suckled in some of my water i think that
that sounds like it was like hey buddy
here
ethan is suckling the microphone for our
audio just so you know
no you've got a word for thirst i'm
thirsty
so what happens when somebody's thirsty
and you give them something
there's no word you suckle there's no
freaking word
how is there no word for that you
is that mind bending
like and and i've gone my whole life too
until this week without realizing that
that's what's weird too
this person is saying i would go with
hydrate
get get real you know what can i have
some water
yeah here dehydrated let me hydrate you
no that's not
right feed i fed him
[Laughter]
there's no freaking word um
for some reason you would say water the
horse water the horse or water the
flower but
it's not for people you could water a
horse apparently you could say feeding
and watering the horses
so you could water the i mean it's a
little confusing let me be honest
half of me expects that somebody's just
gonna say it and i'm like oh of course
yeah uh you tinkle oh yeah have a tinkle
like oh obviously no there's no freaking
word
so i'm i'm looking to this ongoing
debate
i bet you wish there was a chat right
now yeah it would be nice
can we invent a word like what works
with fed
feed and i drink i drank them some water
that sounds weird
feeding schmeed schmeed hey little
schmeed
so anyway let's get on with it all right
i got a good one actually i've never
heard of this word before
apparently this is a thing to slake
someone
okay like a lake hey dan get the frick
out of town
nobody's liking nobody on this show all
right this is a family show dan
um slake that's a new one to me i don't
know
so guys we've got a lot to get to today
oh my god we've got alex jones banned
from every social media
i got some thoughts about that i think
you guys might enjoy listening to or not
it's one of the things when you express
your opinion about something like that
it's like
i liked you i followed you for years up
until this very moment when our opinions
diverged on this one thing
and now i'm going to stalk you and
threaten your family
it's just an opinion folks you might
disagree with it
but it's just my opinion it's not a
right opinion so that's coming up
very excited about that ajit pai is back
in the news
i'm excited to talk about the fact that
me and el are trying to have kids and i
went to a fertile
fertility clinic and scored it in a cup
to analyze my semen
and it was a freaking weird and wild
experience that i can't wait i took
pictures i can't wait to share with you
all no it was something else man
and a lot of other really exciting
headlines i think you guys are going to
love there was apparently in louisiana
we'll save it i'll save it i'll save it
my dudes i'm gonna save it all
but before we get into all of that it's
the goof of the day
what do we got let's break the ice does
the goof of the day work ela
let's break the ice let's see hey
definitely
pierce morgan tries to sound smart
on good morning britain i haven't seen
this one
her forehead's really glowing huh damn
her forehead's very small there's makeup
that is
for glow like you should think she's
trying to be reflective you put it in
here
and it's like glow but that's not a good
look it just looks like she's got a
greasy ass for it i mean
i'm not trying to make fun i shouldn't
make fun of her i'm just saying
i'm just saying it could be that she was
going for that
there is makeup for that i i'm just
saying if you put her at the top of a
light tower and spun her ass around you
could probably navigate some ships home
you know no no
no no no no no no no crickets really
i thought it was right not that bad
yeah so anyway
a brief history of time it's that
history definitely so just avoid those
types yep to treat a girl right
hey have you ever read the brief history
of time by professor stephen
a brief history of time it's that
history so study into black holes
um
to the nearest five decimal places do
you
first what's your favorite color do you
this is like
i'm i'm embodied by so much cringe that
he's trying to like make her look stupid
what did they ask i didn't understand
that have you ever written
a brief history of time by professor
stephen hawking
oh like trying to see like oh you're
dumb
i don't think this girl ever tried to
sound smart i don't think she ever
presumed to be smart
and then so the genius piers morgan
imagine being a grown man dude
and trying to humiliate some girl who's
obviously not the brightest
but she's not out here being like
she's trying to give a phd dissertation
you know
she's dumb and she knows it he's like
have you ever read this book by
professor stephen hawking i mean i
haven't sir yeah who has except [ __ ]
nerds
but like
um she's not up there trying to be smart
dude what are you trying to disprove she
knows she's dumb she's like no i'm not
into that stuff i'm an idiot you know
that
like what's your point and then the best
part is this he exposes himself
to be the real turd sandwich
let's see it you know that the chris
theorem to this
3.147 there's certainly the first four
digits
here's the best part first of all he
names the digits for something entirely
else it's pi and
he gets it wrong nice i don't know that
that's just what they said
that's pine or pythagoras and you knew
that didn't you haley it was wrong
or maybe i've written it but like a
normal person would wouldn't
know that pierce yeah dip
yeah you just showed yourself up yeah
are you humiliated i've
i don't even know how you get back on
the tv after that humiliation
but um so that's a bit of a goof of a
day what were you saying dan ian has an
answer about the drink
situation no i just typed that when you
said only nerds have read that book
ian's like
all right i'm kidding i i i thought
about i thought about picking that book
up
i'm sorry and anne's like [ __ ]
damn ian do you know the pie to the uh
fifth
digit uh no
[ __ ] idiot what a [ __ ] you idiot
uh what else we have one other
announcement good for the day yoko ono
the legendary
uh lover a soulmate of the great john
artist artist yeah don't i don't mean to
discount her she's done so much more
than just be the
soul mate of john of john lennon so
she's come
out with a new album and she released a
new single
that i thought was uh provocative
emotional um incredible moving
moving it's called warzone anyway guys
as i said
pre-orders are available now great while
supplies last
[Laughter]
is it bad to make fun of somebody for
their artistic i'm not i'm not making
fun i'm a doorstep
you're promoting an independent artist
dude i'm promoting it and thank you for
doing that warzone we're just enjoying
some art
and now my dudes on to the main story at
hand
alex jones you all know him the
notorious
conspiracy theorist right wing i want to
say a lot of people consider him right
right wing
i don't consider him right wing i
consider him an alien
i feel like i'm making him affiliated
with the political party is like
aliens trying to pin down like
what country you exist to on mars
i don't know if that made sense i feel
like even mars is too
uh mars is too pl it's too s too
grounded of a yeah
uh well anyway we'll get into that but
essentially you guys know alex jones
um infowars he was recently
banned by youtube apple
spotify and facebook banned all his
channels removed
he um has been making videos since about
early 2001. now today he's mostly known
for
conspiracy theories and he's very right
leaning and that he has a lot of
conspiracy theories and
a lot of targeted opinions about like
hillary clinton
and obama and what what do you call the
the pizzagate stuff he was deep into
i find it kind of interesting if you go
back
into 2001 just to lay the groundwork on
who this guy
is back in 2001 i have this clip from
waking life
he wasn't really a politically
affiliated guy i just found this
interesting he was very much
anti-government anti-party
[Music]
of enemy propaganda rolling across the
picket line lay down g.i lay down gi
we saw it all very much just about the
government system of
control you know very much
he specifically says in this clip like
that
he's not a member of any party so
somehow his his you know
his style has changed since then
regardless um
so this is what happened this is
from verge which is confirmed by youtube
they confirmed this
this information here conspiracy
theorist alex jones youtube channel
received a strike on tuesday for
violating
the site's community guidelines verge
has learned youtube room four videos
from jones channel which has 2.4 million
subscribers
that contain instances of hate speech
child endangerment
sources familiar with the matter set
youtube channels are deleted if they get
three strikes in a three-month period
two videos contained hate speech against
muslims a third contain hate speech
against transgender people sources said
a fourth showed a child who was pushed
to the ground by an adult man under the
headline how to prevent liberalism all
four videos
yeah all four videos are currently
posted on infowars
now obviously i can't speak about those
specific four videos because
it's so hard to find
i mean his shit's been like scorched
earth from youtube and [ __ ] so it's
really hard to find the clips in
question
so i'm just you know reading the
description
uh but this one i do have the offending
video
oh those videos don't include a new one
which was one of his new greatest hits
of him making a threatening rant about
robert mueller
is it mueller or muller mueller i always
thought it's
molar but he's saying he says
we're stirred a controversy earlier this
week after was posted on facebook that
video does not appear to have been
uploaded to youtube post on infowars
said the video had been posted in a news
documentary scientific or artistic
contact
by the way there's anyway the first
reached out to infowars yada yada yada
jones channel previously received
strikes from youtube in february after
it promoted the false theory that
survivors of the parkland shooting were
actually trained crisis
actors that violated youtube's policy
against harassment and bowling
but strikes expired three months after
they are issued meaning jones child
currently
had just one strike against him now
i actually was able to find the clip of
him talking about robert mueller
and i thought well let's let's see what
kind of stuff this guy's saying
because the question right now the real
debate is like is this a
it's being framed by the people who
support alex jones as a political
silencing that he's being shut down
because
all these big tech companies are super
liberal leaning
and it's a it's a it's a political
shutdown
right it's censorship right so i'm like
all right well
like some of the videos they described
could easily be like
completely open to debate like they're
like pushing a children to the ground
it's like i don't know i have to see
that
yeah who knows but here i have this one
of molar
so let's watch this let me pop this baby
open
now this just happened uh very recently
that's the thing
is like once it's mueller everyone's so
scared
that's what he says he's in front of
people what she did so here we go
this is what he's saying that's the
thing now it's like once it's mueller
mueller is like a lifelong republican
solid i mean he's one of the most i mean
that's the same refutable guys
ever like now everyone looks at molar
like he's the [ __ ] or
not a lot but a lot a lot of people see
him as like a total piece of [ __ ] con
man
but i remember donald trump tweeting out
when the investigation started something
like i'm glad it's muller because he's
so respected
so now all of a sudden once it's mueller
everyone's so scared of mueller
they'd let mueller rape kids in front of
people which he did
i mean mueller covered up for a decade
for epstein kidnapping kids flying them
on sex planes
some kids as young as seven years old
reportedly with big perverts raping them
to frame people i mean mueller is a
monster man god imagine
he's even above the pedophiles though so
i mean well right off the bat
can you i don't know if not that it's
hard statements if
i mean you can't really call a guy he's
like dude you've
you've straight up watched people rape
kids
it's like that's kind of what's the word
it's a bold claim
it's not a bold claim it's uh slander
frankly speaking all right
you can't just be like dude i have a i
know
i know for a fact that al jones watches
people rape kids
it's like all right strong statement
let's keep watching i mean slander i
don't
that is slander word is he doesn't have
sex with the kids he just controls it
all
right he's not interested in [ __ ]
kids he just likes to uh
facilitate imagine being a monster like
that
god god don't people say well god aren't
you scared of him
i'm scared of not manning up
dude are you aren't you scared of
talking about this
dude let's give him constantly in fear
that i'm not being a real man and i'm
not doing what it takes and i'm not
telling the truth
and so call it whatever you want i look
at that guy he's a picture
high noon and he's going to find out
when he makes a move man
make the move first and then it's gonna
happen
it's not a it's not a joke it's not a
game it's the real world
politically you're gonna get it or i'm
gonna die try it [ __ ]
get ready we're gonna bang heads i did
notice he actually was saying
politically right now yeah i don't know
what does he mean by that
well it isn't it's very i mean it's very
when you're when you're accusing
somebody of like basically raping kids
i mean we hold that in our culture to be
one of the worst things possible
to the point where you don't even
respect their life yeah when you degrade
someone to the point of being
a child rapist really when you're saying
hey i'm gonna
i'm gonna shoot you if somebody goes if
somebody who believes that he's a
pedophile goes and murders him
am i like if you're to believe that he's
actually like
organizing a massive pedophile ring how
much sympathy do you have for the guy
right so this this [ __ ] you you really
i mean i feel like he's just doing a
character
right and like over exaggerating
everything and it could be
entertaining when you watch it through
that lens but
from what i understand a lot of people
take him seriously and
believe that he is believing what he's
saying so
i don't think he really believes what he
says like about all the
crazy stuff that he well
there that's definitely debatable um
hey guys uh let me cut in real quick um
yeah wow we uh we just got taken down by
youtube
they just killed our stream really yep
why community guidelines wow
we can't even show his footage what
what i'm not because it's been removed
wow how stupid are you youtube alright
we are back um we were live streaming
and right as we were getting into it you
guys saw if you're watching the vod
youtube in their infinite wisdom
removed our live stream and gave us a
strike which basically when you get a
strike you can't live stream anymore
so some genius over at live tube
live i'm having a [ __ ] i'm not
you see what it's doing to me shredder's
freaking out we've been sitting here for
like an hour trying to figure out what
to do
some [ __ ] genius
was like oh they're talking about alex
jones let's
remove the [ __ ] you know what is so
insane
is that my whole rant as i was just
getting into
was very i'm taking youtube's side
that alex jones is a crazy conspiracy
theorist
who violated the terms of service was
doing all this
[ __ ] that shouldn't that by youtube's
terms of service shouldn't be allowed
and what the [ __ ]
does youtube do
they're like you know what we need to do
they'll sit around and think what's the
best thing to do right now
the the most best thing
that will make us look so much better
ethan is defending us
ethan who's defending us against alex
jones right now do you know what we can
do in one fell swoop
to legitimize alex jones
and to piss ethan off and turn him
against us let's
shut his channel down and give him a
strike mid
livestream it's brilliant
let's do that shut it down what the [ __ ]
like how can i even sit here now
and call alex jones conspiracy theorist
when our channel just got striked down
for even
[ __ ] talking about him not even i was
criticizing him
we were analyzing the situation what is
it
how who watched that and thought to
himself
this needs to be taken down right now i
was literally just talking about how he
defamed robert
robert mueller mueller
they're like dude you know what we could
do to make the situation
even worse for us they're like
this was like a beautiful play by them
they're like and one fell swoop
we can turn ethan against us who's
usually critic of us but in this time
he's defending us
we can alex jones there's an explosive
sensitive situation
everybody's saying that it's a
conspiracy theory to censor the
right-wing media
and one fell swoop what can we do
let's all sit and think what's the best
thing got it
strike their live stream and remove
their ability
to broadcast live let me look at my
contacts we do have ethan's number we
could reach out to him real quick
and say hey i don't even know what they
wanted to say but
no no no no no that's too reasonable
you know this is so stupid i have to say
this is so dumb because now
the people that i was criticizing are
gonna use this as
evidence to say hey this is proof there
is a conspiracy against us after all and
you know what
it's hard for me now to argue against
that
do you understand how [ __ ] stupid you
are youtube
uh here let me show you some of my notes
that i was going to talk about they even
knew that we were going to talk about it
they gave you a statement i consulted
with somebody high up in youtube before
this episode to get a statement from
them
here let me show you some of my notes
that uh denver got to air
this never got the air uh blas uh
what's what is it called god damn it
slander against mueller
threats of violence clear violation of
the terms of use
sandy hook was was a crisis actor
because i've got this whole great piece
about debunking that
i was so prepared i can't talk about
this now
how am i going to talk oh there's no
conspiracy
that was [ __ ] defending you
and now i'm offline nobody's even
freaking watching me right now it feels
so weird it's like who are we talking to
nobody
i'm offline i'm off the frickin grid
right now it's just me you
and shredder who's really upset because
he hasn't got walked in two freaking
hours and he's supposed to only be here
for one hour we're supposed to be done
now i even prepared a sound bite
destroy the child because i was goofing
on alex jones so much
you know i'm so freaking pissed off we
had this amazing
edit prepared
it doesn't make any sense now because i
can't go on and on about
all right let me just summarize my
points sandy hook crisis that's
inappropriate
it was oh anderson cooper green screen
debunked it
here's a lawsuit yeah sandy hook parents
are suing
uh uh suing
alex jones because they can't visit
their child's grave because they're
being harassed by lunatics
oh wow who cares
in the five years since uh our son was
killed death threats and online
harassment have forced us
to leave the city and relocate seven
times wow big deal
our channel just got shut down they now
live in a high security community 100
miles away from there where the
six-year-old was buried
i'd love to go see my son's grave and i
don't get to do that because we made the
right decision to move away
destroy the child you see i have
content that story is pretty crazy how
am i supposed to actually like be like
oh yeah
i've got all this gr i mean
i also see a lot of people saying was a
coordinated attack
they just shut us down it doesn't seem
that far-fetched anymore
what do i do do i just show the edit we
made
it's pretty damn good it's such a shame
not to we did prepare and edit
well okay the edit is not really
editorialized
it's really of a immemorial dedicated to
alex jones channel
being removed okay
it's you guys really messed up i'm
looking over i i planned this really
great segment you know
but i can't i can't good mind i can't
say it
because i just got shut down
so with that being said we are just
gonna show you the edit we made
and uh in honor of alex jones who is a
you know a character a hilarious guy if
you will say now it just sounds like i'm
praising him after
the whole [ __ ] list of grievances
it's insane and now now like i hate when
this happens
now all of a sudden i always get [ __ ]
for being like a right wing
a fringe right wing like sympathizer and
now i'm the continue to be the darling
of the right
defending alex jones why do you put me
in this situation
i am not that i am here to criticize and
defend you
and now look where it got me oh
ethan the darling of the alt-right
defending alex jones
thank you for defending him ethan
because you clearly
have a point here
all right [ __ ] sake just roll the edit
for christ's sake
play what do i do commercial after that
destroy the child
they're demons i know your mustache is
cool
you got little gold friend glasses i
will go to hell
i'm animated my heart's big start your
journey to super male vitality
i like to fight too we're gonna stomp
your ass into the ground
you little communist piece of trash i'm
a human and i'm coming
humanity's gonna come together
we know we're under attack
so i never expected trump charging into
a goblin's nest to not get some goblin
vomit
slopping blood on him i don't want to
see him kissing goblins
spider ghosts are at least 25 years old
they're bashing it because i don't like
gay people
i don't like them putting chemicals in
the water that turn the freaking frogs
gay
gay gay i don't like gay people earn the
freaking frogs
[Music]
they'll take all children at birth and
raise them in government dormitories
and do medical experiments on breaking
your jaw in seconds
sandy hook is a synthetic
completely fake without yours i'll smash
your nose into a bloody pulp the new
town kids
they take them put them in our face tell
us their names who they were
do you understand that serious crap
turn the freaking frogs gay day day
thank you to postmates for sponsoring us
i
cannot endorse postmates enough okay oh
there's apps that can bring you food
homemates can bring you food it can
bring you
anything i use postmates on a weekly
basis let me tell you what i use it for
restaurants that aren't on other apps
that bring you food because basically
all the good ones all the good ones are
always not
yeah because you don't have to decide
because a specific driver goes out and
picks up
whatever you want you need some beers
from ralph's
everything pick it up you need some
carl's jr some taco bell late night
or maybe your favorite restaurant guess
what they pick it up
we actually have a friend who ordered a
mac
laptop yeah through postman you can
order
anything and that's what's so beautiful
he was like he's a public figure and
he's like i just realized
i don't actually have to go to the mac
store and stand in line and deal with
that whole thing i sent a postmates
driver to pick me up a computer
a black book i'm telling you this app is
unbelievable it's a life-changing
revelation
introducing postmates the app that adds
a delivery option to your favorite
restaurant
and more you don't have to park you
don't have to drive you don't even have
to talk on the freaking
phone you tell them what you want in the
app they come they bring it boom bob
bob's your uncle
life has changed forever download the
app and order 24 hours a day
365 days a year posters will bring you
what you want within the hour
you can even see where your food is or
your computer
and you can track your driver eggs milk
burgers
perfect bottle of red wine beer
cigarettes they get it
all all
i dare you to try to stretch it to the
limit
post mates is your new long-term
munchies booty call
they wrote that but i i endorse that i
like that and here's the thing
you already don't need another reason to
download this godsend of an app
postmates
here let me give you this limited time
offer postmates gives you a hundred
dollars of free delivery credit
oh can i get that on the house for your
first seven days to start your free
deliveries no ela
you're already signed up i need to use
the code h3
you're gonna have to rate you're gonna
have to factor reset your phone
it's worth it to start your free
deliveries download the app today and
use code
h3 that's code h3 for 100 of free
delivery credit for your first
seven days save the hassle get the food
get whatever you want
whatever you love postmates with code h3
try the freaking app i swear to god
change everything you knew
about being alive postmates
dollar shave club has got it all
why are you wasting your time going to
the store
picking out a shampoo picking out a
razor picking out
butt wipes it's already all set up
as convenient as possible the best
products you're going to find
at dollar shave club get it together all
right how many times do i have to tell
you for
for pizza's sake join the club in the
house
right nice like a nice bow in the house
timing
dollar shave club my dudes they got
everything you need for the bathroom
yes that's dollar shave club they
deliver it so you can look feel smell
your very
dang best they've got shampoo they've
got conditioner
they've got the body wash the toothpaste
the hair gel and even a wipe
my dudes that is gonna keep your ass
glistening
that when you bring that special girl
home you can say you know what
the chinese food tonight baby we don't
need plates because tonight
you're eating my ass what smell that and
tell me you don't want to eat my ass
i'm a big fan by the way of their
they've got this amber and lavender body
wash
that is smells so good that when they're
eating your ass and that big
on the way down they're gonna be like
damn and that body wash scent is insane
amazing good luck finding a product that
great in store
won't happen all the dollar shave clubs
products are made with top shelf
ingredients that won't break your budget
you're gonna feel the difference
shipping is included with your
membership you're going to buy this
stuff
anyway right what are you going to walk
around like a homeless slob you got to
make sure you're clean we'll do a dollar
shave club do the best in the game you
don't have to go to the store for
christ's sake
here's a great way to start a bunch of
dollar shave club products for just five
bucks
you can get their daily essential
starter kit
five bucks it comes with body cleanser
one wipe charlie they're amazing butt
wipes
their world famous shave butter and
their best razor the six blade
executive keep the plates coming for a
few bucks a month and add in shampoo
toothpaste or anything else you need for
the bathroom
check it all out at
dollarshaveclub.comh3
that's dollarshaveclub.com h3
there is no reason not to join get
in the freaking club right now
66 percent of men lose their hair
by age 35 what and when you notice it's
going
it's already too late damn how much
easier
is it to keep the hair you have
than to try to replace it once it's gone
i don't know
is that hairline slowly fading back
yes how will it feel
a year from now is it going to be
business as usual or is your hairline
going to be
broke just like your [ __ ] up life
broke i ask you this
do you want a bald spot to pop up or do
you want to do something about it first
do something do you want your hair light
to recede or are you going to do
something about it
first
why are you turning to weird solutions
are doing nothing at all when you can
turn to medicine
and science the suspense is building
foreheads.com is a one-stop shop for
hair loss
skin care sexual wellness for men dan
show them what it did for you
look at dan's beautiful glistening mane
his hairline was receding
badly was going way back
and now look at him he's basically an
anime character that [ __ ] on the daily
dan is basically people have body
pillows in the image of dan now
that's true thanks to science guys
baldness can be optional
hems connects you with real doctors and
medical grade solutions to treat your
hair loss
there's a well-known genetic equivalent
to a name-brand prescription to help you
keep your hair
okay these are prescription solutions
backed by
science there's no waiting room no
awkward doctor visits save hours by
going to forhamps.com
so freaking easy answer a few quick
questions doctors review and you
prescribe you
your medicine to keep those beautiful
hairs plugged right in your damn head
products are shipped directly to your
door so
order now my listeners get a trial month
of hymns for just five dollars today
right now while supplies last see
website for full details this would cost
hundreds
if you went to the doctor or pharmacy
and let's not even talk about time which
is the most
priceless of all resources available to
man
right saves you that go to for hims.com
h3 that's f-o-r-h-i-m-s dot com slash h3
forehands.com h3 keep that beautiful
head of hair don't let it
fade away like all your dreams have to
this
point in life
we are back and i am still upset
took a little break still mad frankly i
feel like um
i feel a little bit like this right now
i thought the [ __ ] was wise
that's how i feel right now now i
actually did speak with youtube we're
offline
nobody's listening know it's weird
but we so they remove the strike okay we
can live stream
now but i mean obviously we have to
finish offline
yeah we started already we're going to
combine the episodes they said they were
wrong
it was a mistake whatever that means
somebody removed the video it wasn't if
they could let's put it this way they
if they could redo it again they would
leave the video up
somebody's probably getting fired today
yeah right
you think someone's getting fired it was
just some grunt that's how you
what kind of a mistake is that you just
go and give someone a strike
because they have like really obtuse
rules
it's like some grunt who's making ten
dollars an hour in india for all i know
you know what i'm saying and it's like
these these lo this is how youtube's
formatted it's just so ridiculous
it's like formula alex jones video
yeah they they saw it as a re-upload and
not somebody talking about it
obviously you could talk about it so
they said it was a mistake
but like this is the problem with how
youtube formats their company it's so
ridiculous
there's some some it's an anonymous
ridiculous shutdown
our stream they know us they have our
phone number they know
we were going to talk about it it's like
you guys well i never went
i never went beyond you know an 18 year
old
dude's first job who's making 10 an hour
who was just like
i got reported or this matches alex
jones content it shouldn't be
re-uploaded
he opens it and he's like you know what
[ __ ] this guy
it's like damn come on y'all [ __ ]
god damn it all right
i don't know how to move on i know it's
i don't know how we're going to talk
about a
squirting and a cup oh my god
squirting in a cup so upset that we're
offline right now
and the whole episode is so weird now
because like
we're trying like how do you talk about
something else
i'm gonna try let's get off this
so the other week i went to a
fertility clinic
we're trying to have a kid
we don't know why we we've been you know
we've been trying to
i've been trying to [ __ ] knock you up
for like
how long i don't know here
you're probably trying to [ __ ]
make some damn babies sometimes i wonder
i'm like [ __ ] maybe
i see friends with kids and i'm like
damn i don't know if i want to maybe
it's not
happening yeah
maybe we shouldn't do this dogs
i do like to sleep at night i love sleep
i don't like to sleep too much but at
night i prefer to sleep love sleep we
have friends with kids
they're like it's been two years they're
still like yeah we don't have
yeah i hate my life they're like oh kids
are the best
meanwhile like kids are the best thing
you'll ever do meanwhile it's like
yeah i didn't get any sleep i have to
leave every time we hang out at 3 p.m
i'm trying i'm praying to escape my
family for any for five minutes at a
time
yeah it's really great so anyway
it's pretty weird why do we all want to
do it to ourselves
why do you want why do we want kids like
what is wrong with us
it's just if we have shredder he's
perfect yeah he's a perfect angel like
as perfect
as could be i remember how happy we were
when we left him at home for like or we
took him to the groomer yesterday for
like three hours
and we left him at the groomer no i'm
still paranoid about what happened in
those three hours that we weren't with
him yeah
i have a fear that they put a finger up
his ass or something in a weird way
because there are rumors i'm telling you
the truth
our groomers are [ __ ] weird the woman
who
receives him doesn't have teeth she's
literally
toothless she has like a nub rotting
away in her mouth
but it's not a weird it's like a really
nice place yes
but i have to say in a main local area
like it's not like we're taking him to a
weird place we're taking him to a nice
place right
five-star but in my mind
if i were to imagine a lady the [ __ ]
dogs
that's what i would imagine and then she
goes
shredder has this move when he cuddles
with you that he looks inside your ear
no no no
yeah and so she goes
she says to me what i just don't want i
know where you're going with it and i
don't want this thought in my head
well i don't know what happened but she
says to me when we went to pick him up
she's like oh that's his move huh that
he looks in the ears
i was like that sounds like shredder but
i'm also like what situation
is he why is he up there what was she
doing
why was she why was he capable of
putting his tongue in her ear you're
thinking he gives a good head
you're thinking no but i was so wrong i
don't know i was afraid that you were
going to say that she was enjoying it or
something
but not i'm not
he doesn't like peanut butter natural so
that one imagine what her mouth looks
like imagine whatever no okay
looks like
no probably got rotting teeth in the
china
no no
so anyway for those reasons and so for
at any rate
imagine having a kid you leave your dog
for three hours if the sick thoughts you
have in your mind
so anyway i went to i went to uh for
tenure for
utility clinic to
analyze my semen it's a funny situation
that i wanted to talk about by the way
checks out my siemens great
normal normal not he wasn't like dude
you're saving his think
the doctor's like your semen is insane
bro it's normal
he said it's normal that's dank if
you're seeming
normal that's dang so anyway you go to
this little
um it's just this little office
they bring into this back little room
and they bring you into this room and
they're like all right well here's a cup
you jerk and do and when you're done you
bring it out and there's like a little
you know little window you open and then
you put the cup in
and you close it and i guess some other
person back there gargles
they go checks out you see him it's fine
no whatever they do and then why do you
even think about this stuff like would
that be funny though
no because you you imagine there's like
advanced machinery and they looking at
it under a telescope
but it's just some [ __ ] weirdo who
gargles it
they're like it's a little on the weak
side i think it is advanced machinery
yeah it's just a funny thought hilo
anyway i walked into the room and i was
so i was just repulsed
i had i took a bunch of pictures of the
room that i want to show you guys
so let me let me open that up
where's all this [ __ ] on my desktop god
go away [ __ ] off
oh my god kidding me so here squirting
in the
cup pictures got a slideshow for you
guys
so here's the room
hello so here's the room i'm gonna
describe it for our audio listeners
so this so here what are we
so basically now what you're looking at
is headphones
that are plugged in to the tv
okay now look next to it at the wall
there's drip
running down the wall oh yes what
like some dude's just jerked all over
the wall and there's just like
stains on oh my god the headphones are
on the ground it's like imagine you're
putting those on your head
why is it on the ground you look look
dude there's a splooge uh drip
look by the left headphone there's like
a wet drip there
you see that right here might well i'll
put the mouse over it you see this
there's a sploon strip oh you don't see
it
no look there's this hold on right here
it's a sploon strip
oh what
so okay so i was like holy [ __ ] yeah i
am the one
dirty so these are like they've got like
playboys and stuff
in this imagine touching that these
sticky ass
pages little white oh it's coming it's
magazines it's on the wall
they've got like playboys and hustlers
and [ __ ] but like this has been handled
by
thousands of dudes who have jerked off
before you imagine touching that
i feel like you gotta wear like a hazmat
suit when you walk into this room
bro i dropped i was like when i walked
in well wait do you see the chair
so this is more of the same i mean yeah
just look at this chair that's the first
thing you see when you walk in the room
oh my gosh it looks like a torture chair
crazy it's like a b pad like shredders
p-pads
it's like it's like yeah dude that's
fine i'll totally jerk off in that chair
now that you've covered it with
it's a pee pad what do they expect that
you like get naked and sit on that
i don't know you got to do what you got
to do that's the only chair in the room
i did a standing up yeah
no matter how much this chair was
covered i would not sit on it
no i was horrified when i walked in
that's when i decided to get my camera
out when i saw this chair i was like
this is
unbelievable what do they expect that
you're gonna jerk off onto the chair
i don't know you know some weird dudes
are into this
they're like they probably don't even
they do this every week they don't even
need the
it just turns them on this is so gross
here's the cup
yeah so you crack it open you
do the deed and then you have to put the
exact time you squirted
so it was like 11 53 and you know the
exact minute
what does that mean because so you
because i guess you know over time the
semen degrades
so like the minute matters i like it
like right next to the tv remote so
potentially my sema could be even
stronger and they were just a couple
minutes off
right imagine touching anything in that
room
so they've got a tv with like porn on it
and you can put the headphones off and
sit in the chair and jerk off
which was insane i just stood right
there i squirted all over the [ __ ]
chair and everything
no i didn't look at this trash can full
of jizz rags
oh my god they don't even empty that's
what it was when i walked in
just full of rags it doesn't even have a
top like at least use a trash can with a
top or something
just close up why are the headphones on
the ground
yeah i mean there's nothing crazy
there's a little floor
so here's the situation what some lube a
tiny really old tv i mean gosh
then doesn't it cost money to do this
yeah it was like 200 bucks so what's
with the shitty room
they don't even have money for like a
nice error look
tv stand it's all it's all gonna be
on this tiny look i don't know what you
know
i know ladies need some kind of
romancing i literally i was like listen
i'm here i [ __ ] i dropped trowel
it i probably was in and out
okay no sound one minute i didn't want
to spend another second in there
just by being in there with my dick out
i thought i was going to get like
worked this oral thing empty it looks
empty
it's very low evil it's got a lot of use
i mean just imagine like
imagine this you're about to jerk off
with this lube
and you have to touch yeah like even the
act of squirting it out like
they did it's like they're not aware of
how gross ever i need to go in there
like a full body condom
so that's it that's my tour of the i
can't believe you have
but then the weird thing is like you go
in the room and then you
you do it in the cup and you bring it
out and then you have to go back in the
lobby and meet the mer
the nurse so you like go and you face
this
middle aged woman who's like you just
dripped it off
and then you go to billing and some old
ladies like here's your here's your bill
for jerking
off that's so weird like in what
situation can you just
everyone knows you're jerking off and
it's all good
it's a bunch of strangers it's an
interesting thing
so we all did our test and everything is
normal
so maybe we should just not have a kid
because it's a sign from god
well just don't let me back in that room
it's crazy it's a crazy thing
yeah you just sheepishly walk out they
sit your ass in another lobby and
everyone's staring at you like this dude
just drinked off
that's what you feel like everyone's
looking at although they do it all day
they don't even care
no they don't care yeah i wonder if they
ever see a guy like walk out and there's
like some jizz on a shoe or something
probably they've probably seen that
[Music]
[Laughter]
pretty wild stuff um
we wanted to talk about youtube stream
podcast
it's hard to get back into it i'm
exhausted because we've been here for
like five hours
i'm like i'm worthless after a couple of
hours when we do these my voice is
already hurting from talking so much
yeah we've just i mean we haven't even
started
i thought the [ __ ] were
this episode sucks
what else we got agit pie
it's hard to go on i'm exhausted
we got this segment from ian yeah i
think
we'll have to we're going to axe ian
segment should we just bring him out and
do a segment
let's just i don't know it's a let's
just get through this let's see let's
let's slam through it
ajit pai he's back
oh i can't muster the strength to care
about this
i just realized how long has this been
dan
um well because of all the starting and
stopping a little
tough to say let's see uh probably
just about an hour the episode's an hour
long oh my god it feels like we've been
here forever
feels like a week yeah i think we're
actually probably under an hour even
oh my god are you serious
yeah i mean the longest hour episode
ever we've been recording for
uh 16 minutes uh jesus christ
since we came back in from the sponsor
read and i think we broke at the 35
minute mark
sponsor reads about five minutes long so
yeah all right
about an hour edgy pie
you guys remember this [ __ ] idiot
look at this idiot let me show you this
face
you guys got the most goofiest goddamn
face
and i say that only because he's such an
[ __ ]
actually it's facing the article you're
gonna open is funnier
is it let's see so edgy pie the chairman
of the fcc lied to congress about
alleged
cyber attacks that didn't actually
happen so
when you guys remember this huge battle
for net neutrality
we actually made a podcast about it too
um oh let me show this you mean this one
here
i love the framing of that shot i mean i
can't call you can't ever complain oh
that's a bad photo of me
when like your your actual headshot
looks like this
like this guy just he looks goofy in
every photo
come on like that's his that's the
picture on the wall
so this is the guy
this picture yeah you guys don't
remember we've talked about him
so edgy pie during this huge raging
debate about
net neutrality um
god i can't muster the strength to care
about this
[Laughter]
this is so hard so
i mean it is what it is we don't have to
do this this is the failed episode what
we planned is not anymore
anyway they said they got so many people
that were like
[ __ ] you i want net neutrality
that their website crashed and they're
like see how bad we want net neutrality
and the fcc was like
actually you guys have greatly
exaggerated how many people have come
because
the reason our website got shut down is
because
we were hacked and ddos attacked
by people trying to make it look like
there was more people than there were
so they just made it outright lied
because these such a little [ __ ]
[ __ ]
look at this like
how does isn't there a whole team that
has to agree on that statement yes ma'am
they all agreed so it first came out by
like their
their tech person and then edgy pi boy
came out and did a press conference in
front of congress
and said we were ddos attack now
everybody
who knows about tech was looking at it
and being like there's no evidence
we're almost certain that didn't happen
and it came to the point where it was
pretty much proven that they were never
ddos attacked so were they are now
forced to just recently august 8th to
admit that they lied
about an alleged cyber attack that
didn't actually ever happen
because they look like such
idiots i mean this
i'm not surprised this is the guy who
made those videos about
net neutrality in his santa suit so
do they get any kind of punishment for
lying about it
yeah in a sane world but my friend
that is far from the world we live in
but just know that this he got a pie in
the face
but it's not the first it won't be the
last and this i think this guy's just
used to having cream all over his face
you know what i'm saying yep if his face
got creamed anymore he'd look like the
chair in that office
do you know what i'm saying i know
okay i got through that story what else
we got film academy awards
new category at the academy
what do you call those the oscars what
do you call those yeah the oscars
new category at the oscars
outstanding achievement in popular film
because
all the popular films never get
nominated because it's all this art
[ __ ] that nobody's [ __ ] watched
by the way
i kind of agree like the shape of water
who cared about that movie i don't
understand
was like moonlight which was like the
super like i know like 10 people saw
that i haven't seen that one so i can't
tell but i saw
when i was traveling to israel i got to
watch a bunch of movies so i saw the
shape of water and i was like what
who cares about this movie she [ __ ] a
fish
she falls in love with him for no reason
it's like the
the story was so weird i haven't seen it
but eela has a really good
you wouldn't like it i was like let me
let me get this straight
it's a chick flick it's about the power
of love when a [ __ ] can be
so sorry i shouldn't say it like that i
shouldn't frame like that when a girl
i didn't mean yeah she's not a [ __ ]
she's like yeah
i just mean that in like the colloquial
sense but i shouldn't say that
so when a sweet young lovely
misunderstood
yeah because she can't talk she's so
misunderstood she's mute
yeah that true love can still find you
in the end in the form of a giant
fish [ __ ] he looks like a fish
monster or whatever tell me does she
actually [ __ ] him yes
they actually have sex they are
biologically
capable of having sex yes and it's she
does it in an apartment that is not hers
she fills up the i mean i don't know if
this is like if anyone's gonna get upset
for
me spoiling the shitty movie but nobody
cares
um she fills up the bathroom with water
spoiler that they [ __ ]
i don't know i mean i i knew about it
before i watched the movie so i don't
think so
everyone has talked about it already
what if there's a sexual act
they do with the gills no he she
they acknowledged that he has like a
yeah they welcomed out do they ever
acknowledge how big it is
no but she fills up the bathroom with
water
so that they can swim together the
bathroom
yeah she fills up the room with the
water how's that possible not possible
you need to do movie reviews this is
great and then the water is leaking
through the whole building so and
somehow she's a hero she didn't care
about everyone else in the building
celebrated when she destroys
this whole building yes floods this
whole building so she can get a little
fish dick because she's so pathetic and
lonely she can't go over the corner bar
to the dive and get some dick the normal
way
yes and we're giving her academy awards
eli you need to do movie reviews you're
such a hater like in a great way
dude we need ela movie reviews holy [ __ ]
so anyway outstanding achievement in
popular film
it's kind of a slap in the face though
too it's like
it's not a real category it's like yeah
it's it's like associated
fast and furious is the winner
fast and furious 21 is the winner an
outstanding achievement in popular film
everyone stands up and claps to like
fake ass award
they even they even give examples movies
like the guardians of the galaxy and
star wars
films can be nominated for both this new
category and best picture however the
intent of this category is to honor more
popular blockbuster
type movies a la the avengers or star
wars
i mean look if you can't make a good
movie that's popular
both like lord of the rings one i'm
surprised star wars
doesn't win anything yeah why they well
you remember
the star lord of the rings was like
sweeping every year because guess what
it's popular and good yeah
what popular and good makes it
the best and that's when you win
this new category is [ __ ] everything
up because no longer
can you be like popular and good
god forbid and you know what it is it
enables hollywood to be even more [ __ ]
that's true because they're going to be
like well um we'll win this
shitty nominee biggest [ __ ] wasted
time award
because like they also enabling them
they also are gonna make the award show
shorter because they acknowledge that
it's boring and no one is watching
down to a mere three hours from four
are you kidding me i'm an hour and a
half in this podcast and i'm
[Laughter]
rather watch this i'd rather watch her
have sex with her fish for three hours
he's like a fish god he's a fish god
he's probably but they never explain why
they never show like what's so god-like
about him his [ __ ] [ __ ]
they explicitly refer to him as a godly
being what the hell
they say that he's a god yeah he's a
fish god okay
they're like what's godly they're like
what makes them a god they're like 15
inches
it's just so like typical there's like
this evil man who just want to kill him
for no reason for no reason
and then she's the only one who sees the
beauty in him right
so stupid there's got to be a button for
this
destroy the child there's no context i
never did the bit
it's alex jones saying well we did show
the edit yeah we did
um i could do a movie review i hate
dude we need i hate 90 of all movies
that's perfect i don't know if it's a
new segment if it's an h3 video
i don't know movie reviews
so insane well let's start on the
podcast it's kind of embarrassing it's
kind of like the
the segment that i hate on jimmy kimmel
except that you're actually coherent and
have an opinion
he's just doing nothing what's his name
yeah yeah
i mean he just rants incoherently and
it's just because he has an
accent you're like a glorious hater like
you are dismantling this dumbass video
like that's a beautiful thing
i'll think about it i i i anyway but you
know
you guys judge for yourself but i i do
fear that like
but you guys are going to hate me
because i hate movies that you like
probably it's so good though but they
can't hate you because you're so lovable
all right what else we got amazon
glasses
my throat is actually hurting i feel
like i've been talking non-stop for like
10 hours
amazon is patented some goggles
and by the way yada yada the workers
they wear it it's augmented reality so
they work more
effectively here's a picture they look
like ski goggles
it's pretty nuts their warehouse is so
big that they need to create
goggles that gives you it's like a gps
it tells you turn left
turn right to get the product
speculate that this tech is actually
being used to train
deep learning ai so that they can
eventually
throw out all these [ __ ] loser-ass
humans
and just have robots doing it
interesting what's next
we're so [ __ ] when there's no jobs
left you know what i'm saying
anyway i don't really believe in that
because there will be new jobs
you know well there is a problem i mean
like historically it's like people
don't ride horses anymore
so but then it brings new youtube videos
yeah well how many people can youtube
hire no but i mean there's new jobs
like before but it's shrinking because
automation
automation was never a problem was like
shifting fields yeah it was like oh we
don't
need people to raise horses but now
we're building cars and it's a new field
or like you don't need people digging
coal up but now there's all these people
in renewable energy
exactly but automation's a different
issue
yeah so it's literally
replacing people yeah of every job
yeah it's all because you gotta
order your q tips and one day shipping
from amazon instead of walking to a rock
five minutes away from your house dude
you know we're guilty of that
every day anyway what else we got ian
you want to do this uh presentation for
christ's sake
little uzi here's another ian put
together segment for us
lil uzi vert who's a hip hop rapper
he raps he
um he ripped off or let's not say ripped
off he
got inspired by the art of heaven's
gate cult if you guys don't remember
these sweet
very inspired and creative individuals
the heavens
gate colt they were the guys you guys
may recall
when haley bopp came around which is
this comment that comes around
earth about every two thousand years or
so dan is that correct me from wrong
approximately
yeah that's right and um hail bottom
hale bob sounds like i'm such a great
sounds like an artist haley bop
hillbop anyway these dudes
um they actually you know drinking the
kool-aid but these are the guys
they that's their mean they're the
original they're the original
drinks no they were uh applesauce those
guys oh no
it is uh jonestown different different
culture god
can we retake this apple plus what they
do with the apple socks
poison cyanide well they're the nike
they had these sweet ass nikes right i
did hear about the nikes yes
so they all were weren't looking like so
fresh like ultimate sneaker heads these
guys
and they had these fresh ass nikes on
and um
they ate this applesauce with poison in
it and they all said
smell you later earth and in their
they believe that haley bop behind hilly
bop
whatever [ __ ] haley bop billy bob is
it bob
what is it dan i believe it's hail bop
hail bop with a p we can that be
hard at the end or is it a p how do we
pronounce it hale bop
we're fact checking this right now bob
we got the uh my kids bought them yeah
the expert you can get him in there so
hale bop not yet
hail bop comes around every 2000 years
and they thought there's an alien
spaceship the mothership
that cruises behind the comet and if
they kill themselves when it's close to
the earth
they go up to the spaceship i don't know
why they're why are they so eager to get
on that spaceship
ian will be able to answer that for us
what's going on on that spaceship
that's so dope parties i love that they
were all like we've determined that this
nike
is the freshest and we want to bring
these with us
i wonder if today would be yeezys or
what
no they're like these yeezys are the
freshest shoe for eternity
it's too hard to get so what some cold
guys are gonna be like
you know how hard it is to get 10 yeezys
are you kidding me
anyway um so they died and
but and so anyway there's two of them
that they left behind to maintain the
website which is hilarious in its own
right
so here is um their original
art here heaven's gate which is pretty
sick honestly
yeah what does it say as was promised
the keys to heaven's gate are here
again and that fonts kind of tricky
and and do the ufo2
as they were in jesus and his father two
thousand years ago
oh i guess their theories that it passed
last time it passed was when jesus was
alive so he jumped on up to the
spaceship what kind of dumbass
plot is that of jesus to be like yo
i came to this planet to create life and
die for all your sins
but guess what my spaceship only comes
around every two thousand years
and you gotta be wearing knives wearing
the freshest
no jesus was the ultimate sneaker head i
love the
graphic though dude their graphic design
is insane
and like the gate looks like a key so i
don't it's so good
so and his new album art was
here i'll show you obviously like
i don't know if you want to call it a
parody but obviously really already
heavily you know inspired by and and
frankly it's so sick
theirs is better yeah theirs was like
ultimate freshness
as was promised the keys to eternal
outtake are here in
love and rage the ufo two
as a little uc vert and his father 2000
years ago anyway
i love it i think it's great what he did
but guess who didn't
heaven's gate who remembered the two
guys who by the way
probably have a chip on their shoulder
because all their [ __ ] homies are
cruising on a ufo with jesus
having a crazy party with these yeah
like crazy sneaker head party
so they're they got a chip on their
shoulder and frankly i don't blame them
so they're threatened to sue little uzi
vert
and um that kind of leaves us off
with ian who as you know is the keeper
of culture and knowledge
he's here to report on the huge drama
that has been sending shock waves
throughout the hip-hop community
and the earth at large um
he's even been in touch with their
surviving two cult members
he's been in contact he has
communications with them
so with that being said ian please
you're actually i think you were
supposed to come in already if i'm being
frank
hit him with you hit him with the
stinger oh you're waiting for me all
right
okay so um as you guys are setting that
up kind of kind of botched the timing a
little bit
oh my god mind
jesus christ
what happened you have an excuse what
are we thinking are you blind
no are you blaming dan bit it out and
spit it out what's on your mind
nothing there's clearly something on
your mind that you
want to say so if you have an excuse for
what's for this
tell me what's on your mind what's on my
mind is heaven's gate
all right okay you're gonna play it cool
that's fine but this was good at you
know burning the time
i'm
all right well so here we go so ian has
put together
in his classic form a powerpoint
presentation
and once again is the keeper of culture
and knowledge
and power points yeah which we love very
much which is the intersection doesn't
cross very frequently
the powerpoint and the keeper of cult
and youth culture
he's bringing powerpoint
i want to bring powerpoints into the
mainstream a little more i think i'm
glad to hear that it's a great format
so with that being said ian please lead
us on a bizarre journey into outer space
and beyond
okay thank you uh aliens cult and
hip-hop
uh an investigation by ian the intern
that is me
uh you kind of prefaced a lot of it you
know
but i had a little back story with
little uzi vert
grammy nominated rapper uh six times
platinum hit single uh exo tour life
uh cultist huh
do we know well this is the question
that i'm seeking out to answer
emojis thank you damn yeah i had to pay
extra for the emoji pack
you know for the powerpoint no you don't
know how to png
i don't know what's that anymore uh
so on july 6th this is where it all
started lil uzi vert changes his
instagram profile picture to the
following
that's the leader this is yeah this
squidward squidward looking fella look
at that face
and tell me that dude is not on a
spaceship with jesus
right the f now that guy's a cult there
yeah
he's a guy i could get behind i think
also an interesting note
uzi's only following one person and it's
uh marilyn
just manson dramatic yeah it's
interesting so that's what kicked it off
and then on july 31st he releases his
album cover the one you mentioned there
and then on august 1st he tweets the
following
i never really worry because i will
definitely transfer to another body
please come with me i'm part of the new
movement
which those are some ideas from heaven's
gate so do you
okay i'm interested i didn't know that
he was actually
yeah he's did he get the memo because
that comment doesn't come around
for a bit well that's what i asked him
about as
let's not get i mean i'm gonna let you
do your thing okay i'm captivated though
it is interesting uzi wants to ride the
mothership because he didn't just grab
the graphic he's actually saying you
know like
transferring to another body or some of
their beliefs so
uh what all this mean
so what all this means what all this
mean we need to know
so there's them side by side uh
the the bottoms there like uh
here again in t and do those were the
names of the two leaders
da was the squidward-looking man okay t
passed away and then he kind of went a
little loopy that was his wife
or his significant other they were the
cult leaders together
he believes like it says as they were in
jesus 2000 years ago
he believes that he is jesus
the guy is jesus yeah and he's trying to
get back to god
not like he was actually him but he's
been possessed by an
alien spirit that also possessed jesus
2000 years ago
oh damn so jesus was possessed by an
alien
found people took them up and then
came back 2000 years later wow and
grabbed a couple more
so that's that's the belief system there
i gotta say design-wise that g
really nestles into that keyhole way
better than that yeah
it definitely does someone pointed out
to me as well that
like the green bay packers kind of stole
the logo
the g is like the same g dude these guys
are prolific designers
yeah like this design is kind of next
level insane
i know it's great bring me up man yeah
also like the
i have to say the um curvature of the
earth is really like
accurate yeah that's a really powerful
curve curvature of a huge
planet earth but oozy on there you went
a little too much curvature yeah
it's more of like a new ball
so this is the guy marshall applewhite
applewhite white yeah interesting
because then he had them all
kill themselves with applesauce i
thought it was inspired
unwarring white snake a fun little
easter egg so here's a clip of him
your only chance to evacuate
is to leave with us he looks like he
doesn't drink lots of water
about to be recycled
your only chance to he doesn't blame god
survive
okay where did this graduate
is he recorded these tapes
kind of as a way to get people on board
and up to speed
oh this is a recruitment technique yeah
whoa yeah
so yeah in march of 1997
38 members of the heavens gate cult
eight poison applesauce killed
themselves
and attempted to board the comet and
uh they all put on identical outfits in
matching nike decades before the deed
so i have a picture of that in this next
one nice uh
fresh as hell yeah thank you oh they
have a little patch
yeah they designed that patch as well
and they all had it on their
shoulders picture sick uh
the nikes are discontinued and
incredibly rare a few pairs on ebay
are going for around eight hundred
dollars right now that's pretty ordinary
there's so much people are watching yeah
the shoe itself
isn't that nice but it's just
iconic yeah it's interesting how that's
appealing
but uh yeah the remaining members are
threatening legal action
now hold on i'm in i'm fascinated by the
fact that
some of these guys were left behind to
chug the apple juice
or not to chug that you know what i'm
saying yeah yeah they're
left behind specifically to do a couple
just to maintain the website
yeah i asked them about that uh am i
getting ahead of myself do you have you
haven't yet
all right so this is their website like
as it looks today
nice it hasn't changed since 1997. i
love this
motif yeah they really stuck with it
so i was just saying i spoke with the
remaining member to get some
clarification
so my first thing i i said had you heard
of uzi before what do you think of his
music
who designed the original logo it's
pretty eye-catching
they said uh we did not hear of him
before the 31st
very specific we know nothing of his
music
it was designed by a couple members of
the group in the spring of 96
so a year before they all said see yeah
yeah all took off
this is not the first time a musician
has co-opted heaven's gate uh
in 2016 frank ocean used
the same imagery for his song nikes so
here's a picture from his music video
uh and i was like what do you think of
people
where's the inspiration yeah what is
that you can see the in the
the bed there and the nike shoes that's
that's like the picture yeah oh what
they're gonna
come on dude i was just curious
contribute yeah so i said
yeah do you find it upsetting or are you
glad to see that heaven's gate is
impacting popular culture
uh what is the appeal really good
questions ian
i was getting curious they sent me a
whole uh
they understand that it's pervaded the
culture but frank ocean was not
infringing on logos so
right so they're not upset these guys
are like very
business oriented yeah they're very
business very business they don't mess
around can we just acknowledge this is
kind of insane that ian's having a
conversation
with people yeah how did you get in
touch with them
they have you can reach out that's all
they do is answer emails
that's damn one of their main if they
have pages and they don't have a job
they do either they do they don't say
what no did they
i have an idea of what it may be but
they didn't explicitly say
what's your idea do you use that later
yeah okay can't wait so
they told me that they weren't bothered
by that they know that their information
is controversial
artists reflect the social discussion
many are interested in the
information and that the generation z
group wants to learn more and are not as
put off as others have been over 21
years
we are not here to waste our time
eventually they want to seed the planet
and break through with their information
we are not here to harm mankind we are
here to educate and inform
so uh i said you're mentioning that
you're hoping to see the planet
i've come to understand that the next
level that's kind of what they call
heaven
is only accessible every two thousand or
so years with the passing of the comet
is that the only way to get there it's
estimated to return in the year 4380
what are your plans for the next 2 362
years
uh are you ex are you planning on just
spreading the teachings throughout the
next two millenniums by way of
reincarnation because they believe in
reincarnation okay
they kind of sassed me a little bit here
really where did you get the idea that
we time ourselves to space debris
hold on wait the comet is space debris
that yeah apparently the comet
isn't the ufo the ufo is behind it
in like a jet stream but he's saying
that the
ufo can come around any time yeah okay
he says the next level created this
universe and can come and go
whenever and wherever they choose we
don't know when they will return but
we'll be
less than 900 or so yeah okay so they'll
be so
not worried so they're just a quick 900
yeah
i love them were they where did you get
the i love face debris
yeah like you simple mortal yeah
dumb ass for thinking this uh i love
that they say we don't know when it will
return
but it will be within 900 years yeah no
worries okay
yeah yeah nathan fielder would just be
like
okay
i said when the members left for the
next level what was the conversation
like
in which you were instructed to stay
behind how many were asked to stay did
you feel reluctance or possibly relief
whoa uh you know i'm curious and they
said there were no conversations we
received our instructions
all the group departed by 6 p.m on march
24th there were no options
just instructions it sounds kind of he's
there's some baggage there
yeah they didn't really they just kind
of said okay this is what we're told and
we'll have to do it but
but this guy there's there's some real
do you think there's some
yeah like he's just like we're just
loyal
soldiers and we just get an instruction
and follow it
yeah but like you can tell
there's some resentment there you'd
think i mean if the 39 people are going
to like
this space paradise there has to be and
but we need you to stay behind
and do just like [ __ ] you yeah like
they're all
doing their thing you know what i'm
saying he's he's worshipping the
next level yeah yeah we need somebody to
[ __ ] somebody asked me to stay the night
extra to maintain the website i'm upset
imagine 900 years yeah but who's going
to watch like little uzi vert
and see what he is how many were left
behind and how will you reach the next
level
uh they said eight were left behind five
have died of natural causes but
completed their tasks in 1997-98
we two are left in arizona and one is in
los angeles uh
we will rejoin them in a classroom
situation at some point in time
through incarnation what a classroom
situation what does that mean what does
that mean oh i have no idea
oh it sounds like oh we will reincarnate
and rejoin them in a classroom situation
yeah so you're all just chilling in
class breakfast club shredder
you're messing up
yeah so i don't know what the classroom
i kind of love this guy how
this is kind of an old guy it must be
right it's a couple
um the the the couple that live in
arizona i think i'm jumping from one to
the
to the other in these responses oh yeah
but they must be on the older side like
yeah like 60s maybe because the cold
later the cold started
around the 70s so they speak kind of
like old people
yeah yeah no emojis
i asked them as your primary directive
to manage the website and answer
inquiries
do you have other duties i was reading
some of the guidelines for the group and
they're really restrictive
down to like they were instructing how
big your pancakes could be
just for dietary purposes do you have
hobbies outside of heaven's gate maybe
your favorite movie or favorite album
i was hoping that they'd give me
something yeah or
like we love like nacho libre or
something but
uh some did internet stuff media
coverage one was assigned a production
task with filmmakers that didn't work
out
i actually found that story that was a
producer
to make the film and he went on tv and
was talking about it
and he was on probation for auto theft
and they saw him on television in
california with the cult and immediately
went and rested him
i think that sort of fell through
uh so we work full time to pay for
everything
and take care of the group affairs all
the other times so no hobbies no
we have the duties of providing
information they're just very focused on
their i love
the how forthcoming they are though yeah
they're just like dude whatever you
want man yeah whatever you gotta ask uh
so and they got back to you pretty quick
right
what is this yeah they're very fast at
responding
so i found that when they before
everyone went on the spaceship
they the way they made money was
actually a lot of them were programmers
and so this was their old website called
higher source
that they would use to get programming
jobs
and this is on the way back machine in
1997
i don't think it's there anymore so i
just looked at what type of websites
they designed
and if you go on their website design
tab here's a list of stuff they've done
i clicked on one of them this is prima
donna
they designed this website for a
unauthorized madonna cd yeah
was it not who made it uh
it's madonna but it's like a bootleg and
someone hired them to sell this bootleg
cd and they made
this pretty uh awesome website here so
that's how they got their money
uh it's interesting looking at all these
old websites i wonder if you're sitting
on like a
small fortune from these madonna
bootlegs
i'm sure it was a big business still
working some day job hey
somebody's got to pay a hosting bill oh
they are working day jobs right yeah
so i read about the website design were
you one of the designers
have you ever considered updating the
website to make it a little more modern
i could give you an offer code with
squarespace
[Laughter]
and uh they weren't on the design team
so they aren't still designing right now
so i know
they said no thank you the website is to
remain as it was in march 97.
really good job promoting our sponsors i
wanted to
if i wanted to reach the next level what
are the main steps i should take
traders destroying the power cable by
the way
[Music]
i read that the next level is an actual
planet is there an actual hell
to like mustafar in the outer rim that's
where uh
is that a reference i'm not getting
that's where obi-wan cut off
anakin's arms great uh
the next levels across the universe
there are no steps that can be taken in
this era
so if you want to go now you're kind of
out of luck
um you're ranked number seven on watch
mojo's list of top ten
what do you think of that i i thought
that was the
[ __ ] uh
i mean i figured that's kind of an honor
right we don't think watchmojo means
that much
shots yeah
what is the biggest misconception you
believe people have when it comes to the
group
that the members were weak-minded
gullible and brainwashed just the
opposite is true
uh i read that the group purchased alien
abduction insurance from a uk-based
insurance provider prior to march 24th
is
is this true this is like a rumor
floating around
and it's on their wikipedia that they
bought alien abduction insurance
uh there's actually a company in uh the
the
best business ever to be in how much
does it cost for alien insurance
there's a anyone listening right now if
you want alien insurance
email me i'll assure you there's a
company in the uk and geico has a report
on it that uh
they've sold over thirty thousand
insurance policies holy spirit alien
absolutely
that is the best business
they said that they looked into it but
didn't buy it the internet turned a
humorous inquiry by us
into a weird insurance event that never
happened it was blown way out of
proportion
so they just goofed so this is
uh i this is pretty pretty
in a short way i asked if little uzi
vert could help carry the torch and
spread the word
sure if he is open to learning with this
new movement he mentions or does he not
have what it takes
they go little uzi vert would have to
make a dramatic change in his grasp of
what the next level is really like
it would fizzle right so they don't
trust him to carry on
at a concert recently this freaked
everyone out where he said dude you guys
are basically an old friend
i know i feel like you're like one i
feel like ian's gonna
show up covered in a blanket with some
nikes on in a couple weeks uh
after i don't know if i'm gonna stop
talking get sucked in i know i'm saying
i'm concerned
i've started to rethink some things i
may need to get some insurance
i got you i assure you at a concert
recently uzivert kind of freaked out his
fans because he said
you uh you all have entered the rapture
no one's flying up to heaven
obviously all of you are going to hell
ride with me
you're already here so sorry you can't
get out you're stuck it's over
you heard the songs a million times you
didn't even know
so he's saying that his songs are like a
gateway to getting people to go to hell
that's a pretty foul thing to say to
your fans yeah and i was just like
what his fans got kind of freaked out
but expecting like the ground to like
open up from batman
yeah i asked what do they think of this
if you say little oozy verb fast enough
it sounds like lucifer
little lucy vert lucifer and uh
i i they said he does not know the ways
of the next level
everything he talks about has nothing to
do with us he has to comply with
copyright
law dude what's with little uzi is he
really like
nah he's just doing an act yeah okay
yeah that's how i sit i'm splitting this
is a picture that's on
him on his facebook his official
facebook
is lily's vert starting a uh luciferian
space cult and dragging his fans to hell
is kind of the question that looks
pretty serious that painting i don't
know that's
the official painting yeah anna
nicki minaj released a song this morning
one of the lyrics was like
when i told uzi to go to hell i didn't
mean it literally
and that's that's today his
representatives did not respond to quest
for comment
i reached out to uzi's uh people he did
yeah
is a little izzy verb planning on
starting a space called who's ever
demon should i be scared of missing i
love how credible your
inquiries look ian
they didn't answer and i have no
responsibility
i have no idea why they wouldn't answer
us this reputable
h3 podcast no to us ian
so the moral of the story really after
all this is beware of rappers offering
you applesauce
you know it may be poison sure don't get
sucked in just don't eat applesauce
who's eating be safe avoid applesauce
all together because what are you
if you're over at the age of a year yeah
yeah
yeah uh watch out for guys that look
like this
this is a photo taken from their
websites on the landing page
how a member of the kingdom of heaven
might appear
so if you see a guy you got a dope-ass
tracksuit pop-on
like some adidas [ __ ] yeah everything
about snickerheads
they're all very fashionable so if you
see that guy walking around you know
look out
and get some abduction insurance really
good and that's uh
that's the end so that's what we've
learned give me some applause here
that was another great presentation by
ian the intern
i tell before i send you out tell me
about your how
was it reporting that how was it talking
with the members of this
infamous cult i mean did you feel a lord
because they had some kind of a
business-like charm i'll say
did you feel like you wanted to hang out
with them tell me
did you learn anything yeah i
well at first i was like oh god are
these people gonna
you know be weird and freaky and try and
find out what like scientology
will kind of come for you yeah these
guys have kind of been like
we're good we got 900 years to chill out
so they're not very
urgent they're pretty relaxed just don't
mess with their copyright
yeah most definitely well apparently
they are not suing they're threatening
to sue
they're threatening and now he seems
like he may be changing he's backing off
yeah wow so it's an interesting story
that's a shame
all right thank you anne thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
guys thank you for watching remember to
hit up
represent.com h3 for this sega ass
two weeks only available grateful dead
merch
inspired merch this was a rough ride i
maybe we'll do the alex jones segment
later because i think it's good but i
just can't do it now
i feel so exhausted man hope this was a
watchable episode it was a wild
weird freaking twisted ride
and now we have to upload it tomorrow
because it's already like
six takes eight hours i mean it takes
till eight to put it up it's too late
we gotta upload it tomorrow hey
oh well so guys stay tuned because we
have got
a slamming schedule jacksepticeye burke
chrysler
tim heidecker adam carolla looking good
for the hp podcast yeah
as long as we don't get banned from live
streaming on youtube everything's
looking
up for us and
remember we'll see you in the next level
thanks for watching mother ship is in
the sky and i'm about to hit your ride
that means kill myself
um alright guys catch you next time
[Music]
you